how do you keep yourself busy in between
acting jobs I mean are you one that
stresses out if the phone isn't ringing
or you have to like always be doing
something or you more able to just trust
that the right things going to come and
you're going to put feelers out there
but you kind of take your time with it
which what's your life like in between
projects I think with a minute within
the last ten years I realized that you
can't just be an actor anymore so I
produce indirect at the time earlier in
my career I did short films so that's
what I did to kill the time because you
get to be creative with your friends
it's like back in there you know 50s 40s
50s the actors would you know get
together and create little you know
theatre groups so we create little film
worms out here in LA and we just film
each other and put each other on tape
and it gives us a like it's like going
to the gym with your friends we did
charity yes and that was about a woman
who had a bad day and was in sort of
this negative spiral and and yeah you
know I mean we do lunches a lot in this
town we go see movies as actors we go to
lunches we play golf we go to the gym I
always say I'm running errands that's
sort of what I do in my downtime which
means I'm going to lunch and the post
office box you know to pick up my
so that's the one thing that we were
doing one time is we were having lunch
in santa monica allie ray who's the
actress who wrote charity and she was
just telling me about her god awful day
and I said that would make a great story
so she wrote it and then gave it to me
we tried to look for a director because
I was just acting at the time that she
gave me the script and then she said why
don't you direct it asking me if I would
I said if you find the money I'll do it
and so within a week she found the money
so I did direct the short film it was so
much fun because I got to work with all
these people that I've worked with as an
actor I got to bring them on board this
production and we had a great time it
was a lot of fun I mean you you really
see how wonderful people are when they
like give you their their house when
they bring food to the set and they're
doing all this pro bono is because they
care and they about us and myself so
it's really wonderful that's the most
beautiful thing I got out of making the
short films is seeing how many people
really just want to be creative it's
never really about money it's just about
wanting to create art if you know you
can make money on it that's great but I
think initially at the core most people
in this town or in this business really
just want to be creative and create some
form of art whether cinematic or or
other
you